the secret language that we all speak
means every bit of nonverbal
communication that we use to interact
with other people in our relationships
and the interesting thing is that we are
all experts in it so everybody that
walks into every lecture that I give is
already an expert just navigating the
line at coffee and traffic and walking
on public transit you're speaking that
language in negotiating who moves out of
the way
what gestures do you do and who takes
what seat is all communicating in this
language of power an example cocktail
party there's a circle of people you're
standing around talking and someone
starts to approach that circle of people
is going to either open up and invite
that person in or it's going to close
ranks a little because it's not for
whatever reason okay for that person to
enter the conversation needs to go a
particular way because of who that
person is whatever the context that
happens all the time it happens in bars
and at coffee houses everywhere we go so
that's also communicating in this
language of power and it's something we
don't think about the group doesn't have
a vote on how we're going to behave they
just react then it's six or seven people
reacting to small verbal cues small
nonverbal cues all simultaneously
any one individual can change the
dynamic of the group or the person
they're with and they do it by a set of
behaviors what we're talking about is
the difference between being more
authoritative or being more approachable
so if you want to joy the circle you can
enter the circle before you even
approach it by calling out someone's
name and that puts you inside that
circle already you could come up and tap
someone on the shoulder or gently nudge
someone and all of that nonverbal
communication is asserting I'm here I'm
taking an authoritative approach that
I'm going to enter it's a little on the
dominant side of things
conversely if you're in the circle you
can decide I'm going to let that person
in and you can use your power from
within the circle and take up the space
and say I own this and because I do come
and join me come into my space I'm
holding in the circle here and I'm going
to let you in and share my power with
you
I typically show up with a little bit
more motion my head's a little to the
side and I tend to be friendly in fact
people come up on the street and ask me
questions all over the world when I'm
not local directions or other things
because I'm that way but I can change by
just making myself a little more still a
little more upright I can make my voice
go a little bit lower into my chest
voice I can speak a little bit more
slowly and I can leave more space in my
words slow down my gestures I would say
across that last 30 seconds I became a
lot more grounded and authoritative and
like you would believe the directions I
was giving you in London even if I
didn't know them
conversely if that's how you always show
up if you tend to be in this slow place
you can make small changes you can talk
just a little bit faster maybe you can
tilt your head a little bit you can nod
maybe you know touch your chin a little
bit as you talk or a little bit more
gesture with your hand and I think this
is a little friendlier it's a little
softer so just by making those small
changes two things happen one I'm
communicating to you a different set of
social cues about that you can approach
me or that you shouldn't
and as it turns out by changing your
body you change your internal state in
one place where I'm more authoritative I
will begin to feel more authoritative
just by taking on those gestures and I
will feel a little more friendly and
approachable by taking on the other set
of gestures so it works both ways you
can decide to be it inside and it will
come out naturally and you can decide to
put it on physically and it will go
inside
after you start thinking about this you
can't avoid it you'll see it as you walk
across campus or as you go to get a
coffee but it's just the background
that's happening because it's naturally
how we communicate you don't have to
make strategic choices all day long that
would be exhausting but most of us have
learned this navigation as children and
as we come up and we sort a lot of it
out in junior high school it's all these
social cues and it's just how we
function in the world so we're on
autopilot most of the time and that
works great for 90% of the people it
works great there are a few but it works
great all the time when it's really
important when it makes a difference you
might want to consider some different
choices when it's an important meeting
for you when it isn't going well when
you're having a challenging situation
these are the points where you want when
it might want to stop and take a thought
and a little bit of action and then you
can go back to just being you because
most of us are successful well adjusted
people that navigate this without
thinking and that's how it should be
often when we come home from a stressful
day and we walk in the house we carry
all of that along with us and it just
comes along because that commute was
rough and that guy cut us off and and
all of that's inside and as I said
what's inside comes out and so we walk
in the house but you can stop right at
the door and take 30 seconds or a minute
and reset think about what's on the
other side of the door how much you care
about them how you want to show up for
them what fun you have had or planning
to have and that will start to change
you you can put a smile on and change
your body and then when you walk through
the door you're a different you
everybody's fear primarily is that the
way they are isn't the way they should
be that what if I was the other side of
the equation and then most people are
afraid of actually being powerful they
say they're not our students come in and
they they act in powerful ways but when
we push them to really step into it it's
a challenge and there are a number of
poems and songs that are all written
about this but the thing that we're
really most afraid up is being powerful
to stand in a very confident really
stand in your power is a scary place to
be and if you can do that then you can
change the world
you can change the people around you you
can lead people to do things and
accomplish your goals and it's an
incredible place to be and when I coach
someone and they step into their power
the first time ever they have a visceral
reaction it's an emotional experience
and they feel incredible and it's
frightening and exciting and scaring at
the same time so the thing that the
secret the thing they all want to know
is how to stand in that place and be
comfortable
you